hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2022 russian science fiction and
thriller movie called project gemini
the movie begins with the news report
showing the earth's ecosystem is being
destroyed by an unidentified deadly
virus
several efforts from world reputable
scientists have been made but none of
them were successful
because of that natural disasters
occurrence increases significantly and
everyone predicts that earth will be
uninhabitable in a short period of time
meanwhile dr steven ross who is leading
the project gemini or earth 2.0 project
and his fellow researchers just
discovered an ancient extraterrestrial
object named the sphere which they
believe can be the life creator and an
unidentified engine
project gemini's team manages to
duplicate these alien objects with the
same exact materials and discover a new
inhabitable planet called tess with a
machine as it allows humans to do deep
space travel
not only that they have successfully
cracked several codes to utilize the orb
since it has its own language and
planned to create a new home for mankind
with it
stephen and his team consisting of leona
peter david and mayor ryan connell are
going to do an expedition to test to
directly witness the planet's condition
and install the sphere there
steve's wife amy tries to prevent her
husband from going away but she is too
late as the spacecraft has departed
while steve and peter are checking the
engine suddenly something pops out from
the sphere indicating that they are not
alone
after traveling in space for a while the
crews finally are ready for the jump and
commence the jump procedure
however something goes wrong during the
jump and they eventually arrive at an
unknown part of the galaxy
steve blames peter and kicks him out of
the cockpit accusing him for not
following the jump protocol but peter
insists that he had checked everything
before they jumped
they are fully trapped in the galaxy and
cannot jump back since they cannot find
familiar landmarks and data to describe
their current position
on the other side peter turns off the
surveillance camera and decides to
examine the engine alone
not long after the spacecraft reports an
object is approaching and turns out it
is peter's dead body
the entire crew becomes panic and
hopeless
david believes that peter commits
suicide after he has failed the mission
after grieving they realize that there
is a nearby planet which turns out to be
a much better subject for terraforming
than tess was
steve as the mission leader decides that
they will try to explore the planet but
ryan and richard disagree because it is
too risky and the planet is still
unstable since it is a young planet but
their opinions don't matter as steve is
the one who makes the final decision and
the other crews have to comply
the docking sequence is requested and
ryan steve and several crews head closer
to the planet
after passing through the rough weather
the field crew managed to land on the
planet
the scene briefly jumps to a moment when
steve gives his wife a beautiful jewelry
made of spheres material
despite landing safely richard reports
that the plane is out of fuel meaning
that they can't get back into the mother
ship and are trapped there
they find a suitable cave and
immediately prepare for taking out the
sphere into the cave
upon arrival at the cave they begin the
installation of the sphere after that
they return to the plane
meanwhile richard who is alone in the
mother ship discovers a transparent gel
and coincidentally finds a recording of
peter before he was somehow expelled
from the ship
that evening he tells the other crews
about the recording revealing that peter
was killed by an unidentified being not
suicide
he also discovers that the life being or
so called the trojan horse was coming
out from the sphere and is currently on
the cruise plane
ryan realizes that steve is hiding
something about the sphere and urges him
to tell the truth to the entire crew the
scene moves to steve examining the
sphere on earth where he suddenly comes
across an unidentified human being he
refuses to discuss the anomaly he found
earlier and walks away it is revealed
that david's daughter passed away just
before the expedition and steve
initially suggests he withdraws his
intention to join the journey but he
insists since he is the one who has the
best understanding about the project
alongside with steve
back to the plane steve asks david to
join him quietly back to the sphere at
first he refuses as ryan is now the one
who is taking control but he changes his
mind after steve tells him that they are
humanity's last hope to defeat the
emerging virus on earth
upon arrival they adjust the setting of
the sphere when the trojan is slowly
approaching them david panics and starts
shooting the sphere which deactivates it
they immediately run back and barely
make it to the plane
afterward ryan confronts them warns
steve that he no longer has the right to
make decisions
suddenly the plane alarm is triggered
indicating that the trojan manages to
break into the plane
leona who is still confused about the
emergency situation walks through the
corridor and accidentally spots the
trojan in the lab
fortunately she still makes it to the
control room
all crew members have gathered at the
control room where the trojan cannot
break in
since the plane's main generator was
broken they lose contact with the plane
and are unable to access the camera
steve volunteers himself to connect all
the electronic devices to the backup
generator in order to restore the
security camera and communications
after a breathtaking moment steve
manages to restore the plane's power and
gets back safely to the room after being
rescued by ryan
they plan a strategy to lower the trojan
outside the plane where steve will be
the main decoy he manages to temporarily
trap the trojan in a chamber while the
others prepare to unlock the airlocks
after all airlocks are open leona
manually releases the trojan which
immediately runs towards steve who has
been waiting outside the plane near the
engine nozzles frank tries to distract
the trojan for a while until the engine
is turned but it is too late
steve retreats to the ship while the
trojan gets back to the cave lucky for
them they managed to collect one of its
tentacles the scene jumps back again
where amy urges steve to walk out from
the expedition mission but he insists
even after she reveals that she is
pregnant on the other side she is also
developing a vaccine for the virus
since then their relationship is getting
worse and amy is unwilling to talk to
him again
she throws away the bracelet and walks
away the next day steve examines the
tentacle in a fragment he finds out that
they were made from the same material as
the sphere while david is lying weak
after being infected by the virus
he eventually learns that the tentacle
is a transporter ryan has lost his trust
to steve and decides to lock him in the
lab
he continues his experiment with the
tentacle and the fragment and discovers
that all this time they didn't move in
space but they time travel to the past
or to be exact traveled to four billion
years ago
richard then realizes that the planet in
front of them is actually planet earth
steve states that the fragment is the
exact same piece as the one he gave to
amy he also figures out that the sphere
on earth now and the one they installed
are also the exact same sphere but just
in a different time
since they cannot save people on earth
steve plans to tell amy about the virus
and indirectly help her to create a
vaccine
he knows that the sphere will remain at
the cave until that day and also he will
give the fragment to her
thus he will write a message for her in
the fragment telling her how to connect
the sphere he is confident that amy will
miss him and eventually will come back
to the bracelet and find the code
meanwhile ryan who still doesn't know
the truth plans to blow up the sphere
richard now supports him and unlocks the
lab urging him to reach ryan in person
and explain everything
he suggests they lure the trojan into
the plane and use the bomb to destroy it
however david suddenly shows up and
shoots everyone he has lost his mind
stating that no one has to suffer since
no one was being created
steve manages to shoot him and force him
away after that steve activates the bomb
and lures the trojan into the plane with
a flare
the beast arrives finally revealing
itself and gets steve cornered but he
still somehow manages to escape he is
then confronted by david who is impaled
by the trojan
he eventually flees from the plane just
before the bomb explodes and blow up the
entire plane
steve becomes the only survivor but he
only has one hour since his oxygen tank
was shot
in the middle of the storm he
immediately walks back to the cave and
reactivates the sphere
meanwhile on present earth amy who finds
the bracelet with the code written on it
immediately runs to the sphere and
successfully activates the sphere the
sphere allows her to make contact with
steve who informs her the equation and
the ingredients needed to make the
vaccine
before he disappears steve apologizes
and expresses his feelings for the last
time
at the end of the movie amy gives birth
to the child and manages to develop the
vaccine
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching